have you ever been in a situation where
you just reacted you didn't process what
was happening you definitely didn't
consider the context and you definitely
didn't think about or choose your words
you simply reacted and you wish you
could just go back hit rewind and
respond thoughtfully maybe was an
argument with significant other a
disagreement with the close friend or
maybe it was at work when you're in that
meeting and someone dismissed you or you
felt offended or maybe here it was in
this very class with one of your
classmates from across the room raised
his hand and said something absolutely
ridiculous and you reacted I'm probably
guessing your reaction didn't have that
outcome that your desired my wife will
tell you that when I react and don't
respond it gets worse a lot worse and
you wish you could just go back and
respond not react like many 60 year old
boys going to high school here in the US
when I was that age the three most
important things to me at that time were
sports sports and wait for it sports and
around 16 and a half we could probably
update that list to read sports girls
girls girls and more sports I was
definitely a late bloomer
now my sport was soccer I was the poster
child for adidas for all day i dream
about soccer I would do those soccer
balls in my notebook and I would play
soccer at any chance I could get high
school soccer team California is a
winter sport team selections in October
intense month of practice and training
in November all in preparation for the
heart of the season in December and
January with league playoffs being the
last week of January heading into
January our team was undefeated we were
excited expectations were super high
personally I was playing at my best I
was leading our team in goals scored we
were prompt and we knew we'd be facing
our toughest opponents in the month of
January small complication Ramadan or
the Islamic month of fasting and self
purification also fell during January
that year now to be honest I didn't
really think twice about it I would do
Ramadan and I would do soccer and I know
a lot of you're probably thinking what
that doesn't make any sense not eating
and drinking during the day for 30
consecutive days for an incredibly
active young person probably not the
smartest thing but like I said I wasn't
concerned i look forward to ramadan
every year it was my mental physical and
spiritual boot camp and i love soccer
you couldn't keep me off that field i
would do both fast forward three weeks
it's the last week of january it's the
last week of ramadan and it's about to
head into league playoffs and so our
coach coach molina who was an
intimidating man just about as wide as
he was tall gather the team as he would
before any stretch of important games
and instead of talking about team
strategy or what the lineup would be or
what our opponents look like he brought
the team together and said lads kickball
and he always referred to us by our last
names for some reason Iqbal has been
fasting for the past three weeks and
coach and I have been wondering what
that feels like and I know we have a
tough week ahead of us probably the most
important week of your lives up to this
point but coach and I have been
wondering what it would feel like to
experience four 8-balls been feeling and
we're going too fast alongside of him
for the next week and we consider that
we ask that each of you consider fasting
alongside him
even if it's just for a day or two both
my coaches and each and every one of my
18 teammates facet alongside me for the
next week my peers in my mentors
accepted me for who I was and how I
chose to practice my faith it was an
incredibly powerful moment in my life
and it's helped shaped Who I am today
but more importantly it's helped shape
how I interact with and impact others my
teammates and coaches stood alongside me
and complete solidarity I was different
perhaps even strange but they chose to
respond with complete love and
understanding rather than react out of
fear we're faced with an everyday choice
respond or react oftentimes we find
ourselves thinking hey I react all the
time it's it's part of my genetic makeup
it's a throwback to my reptilian brain
will react when we feel fearful when
we're concerned when we feel
uncomfortable insecure defensive or
protective when we react we have a
motion and our actions and our words
just tend to come out but reacting is
rarely in our best interest responding
on the other hand it's hard it's it's
it's a actual choice it takes effort
responding requires us to have a more
authentic perspective to have a higher
level of thinking but it's worth it when
we respond it allows us to engage to
listen to learn and hopefully to grow
fast forward 15 years from when I was in
high school to current day my cousin's
Ed's in the eighth grade here in San
Jose and his sport is basketball he is
absolutely obsessed with basketball now
before he could try out for his hat for
his middle school basketball team he
needed to go to the doctor to get a note
clearing him to participate in school
sports so Zedan his mom went to the
doctor someone they've known and trusted
for an incredibly long time someone
they're familiar with and they have a
physical exam now if towards end of the
physical exam the doctor suggests to
both there than his mom
hey you should consider an HPV vaccine
now that it's available for boys and
dads age and Zeds mom nods and thanks to
dr. and says well Zeds a Muslim you know
Muslims don't engage in premarital
relations now if you can imagine that is
incredibly embarrassed he just heard his
mom say primera relation in front of the
doctor super awkward and the doctor nods
and reacts well mrs. Hudson lots of good
little Muslim boys grow up and end up
throwing bombs with Osama you could have
heard a pin drop in that exam room the
doctor really just go from HPV vaccines
to terrorism zetts cheeks turned bright
red his moms too I asked that how did
you feel in that moment what did you
feel and he said you know I didn't
really know what happened but I knew it
was wrong it just felt wrong think about
the impact my teammates had on me and
incredibly young age and imagine the
impact of the doctors words unsaid on
how he views himself more importantly on
how he will interact and impact others
respond not react
I shared my story with you and I sure do
that stay with you but I'm pretty sure
that these could be your own story in a
different shape or different form maybe
it's a story of a personal interaction
involving race religion gender a mental
or physical illness perhaps it's a story
about an obvious difference or a not so
obvious difference maybe it's a story
about how someone impacted you or
perhaps about how you impacted someone
else did you respond or did you react
did someone respond to us or do they
react as we strive to change lives
change organizations and change the
world I asked that we make every
personal interaction and opportunity to
make an impact to really be present in
the moment and to respond thoughtfully
and I ask that we take it one step
further let's not just focus on our
words and on how we say things but let's
consider our thoughts and how that
impacts our behavior do we find
ourselves rolling our eyes when we
disagree with someone do we find
ourselves giving someone an awkward
stare when we feel uncomfortable so the
next time you're here in class and your
classmate from across the room makes
that incredibly ludicrous statement step
back and respond and when you're at that
business meeting and it's been a long
long day and that one person who always
has to disagree raises her hand and
starts making that point fight that urge
to just shut off and listen and respond
and if you ever see me or one of your
Muslim classmates tucked away into a
corner of the vast library with their
forehead on the ground prostrating your
prayer don't pack up all your things and
scurry off I can hear you
but here's the space to finish and when
you see us meet us and greet us and
respond to us with a smile or even just
warm eyes think about the person you
would like to be are you simply reacting
or are you truly responding thank you